Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and welcome to
anime club reboot edition.
Today will be all about the best anime reboots
and sequels in honor of the fairy tale, fate/stay,
Pokemon, Jojo’s Bizzare Adventures, black
butler and sailor moon all coming back.
First things first, congratulations to the
winners from last week’s miyazaki edition.
Melaknee, you won the Studio Ghibli DVD and
Izzy Goggin, you get to choose any series
you want for a future anime club video.
I’ll be messaging you both for details.
I’ll be randomly selecting one subscriber
from the comments to receive a figure of their
choice from the crunchyroll store (twenty
five dollar max).
and one random subscriber to pick a topic
for a future anime club video.
So let’s start with our top 5 anime reboots
and sequels If you want to add any just make
sure to say why you thought it was awesome
or terrible.
Number 5 - Evangelion.
The tv series original ending was so confusing
that the first film was made to provide some
clarity.
It wasn’t really until the second film that
I was blown away.
That film is really the reason I put this
on my list.
That being said most of the reviews of the
third film make it sound like it goes overboard
on the visuals and is kind of hard to follow.
Like one giant boss fight.
There is a fourth movie being made for 2015.
So hopefully that will address some of the
criticisms.
You can’t just spend all of your time in
a boss fight.
Character development is important.
4 Jojo’s Bizzare adventures.
The OVA series from 2000 still holds up today.
Originally there were two OVA stories but
they told a single story.
The funny thing is that the newer series told
the first half of the story.
So there’s this weird effect where the animation
quality drops dramatically as you reach the
second half of the story.
Both have this really classic hand drawn 90s
style to the animation.
My favorite aspect of the story were the stand,
their spirit companions.
they could take different forms.
Not just humanoid, but also objects and elements.
3 Ghost in the shell stand alone complex - I’m
talking about the laughing man arc.
I was a huge fan of the film and the laughing
man episodes really embodied all of the best
aspects of the original.
The character designs were changed to resemble
the manga and because it didn’t have the
time constraints of a movie, the character
development was so much better.
The only real complaint I had about it was
the confusing plotting of the laughing man
episodes and the one-off episodes.
2 - Hunter X Hunter 2011 - There are so many
things to love about this.
The character development is great.
It actually follows a classic shounen style
where you see Gon evolve over time.
And it’s not just jumping from one battle
to the next.
But the battles are amazing.
They’re plotted out in this really strategic
way that reminds me of some of my favorite
rpg games.
This is a really good anime to watch if you
like a story that’s easy to follow but has
amazing characters and a great soundtrack.
I listen to the character’s themes sometimes
when I’m playing games.
1 - Fullmetal Alchemist Brotherhood - In my
opinion, the best anime remake of all time.
A lot of the fandom considers brotherhood
to be a much truer adaptation of the manga.
It also introduces new characters throughout
it’s run which is pretty rare for anime
series.
If you have a friend that wants to get into
anime, this would be the series you would
want to show them first.
And it’s all on netflix.
Even though there are a ton of characters
by the end, all of them are well developed
and three dimensional, even the villains have
hearts and clear intentions.
And as an added bonus, the dubbed versions
are good.
Most of the time I would say stick to subs,
just because original voice casts tend to
be better.
But in the case of brotherhood the dubs really
hold up.
The only real criticism I have of it is that
the animation on the early episodes isn’t
quite as spectacular as the original.
I think they were probably just trying to
save money for later episodes.
Everything still looks great, but the early
animation is just a weak point.
Now it’s your turn to let me know what your
favorite anime remake or sequel is.
And bonus question.
It’s still going on right now, but what
do you think about the idea of an avatar last
airbender anime reboot.
Like a reboot of the original series?
Next week we’ll I’ll be doing my top 10
anime characters, be sure to subscribe to
get my video.
I’m not sure what I’ll be giving away.
But just like normal I’ll pick two random
winners and the other one will get to pick
a future video to do.
Right now click here for anime club episode
2 and click here for anime club episode 1.
Thanks for watching.
see you guys tonight for space dandy.
High fives!